[Music]  foreign  [Music]  my story is true  I am a solitary creature by Nature  I have no children nor siblings nor  parents I did once have a husband  if there is fate who can say  but in the Grand Bazaar of Istanbul I  chose a memento  I like it whatever it is I'm sure it has  an interesting story  [Music]  so what would you wish for what is your  heart's desire  [Music]  I do have a question  what does one do with three wishes  you'll see  [Music]  oh  [Music]  there's no story about wishing that is  not a cautionary Tale  we all have desires even if they remain  hidden from us  but it is your story and I cannot wait  to see where it goes  oh how it might end  thank you  foreign  he'll be staying for a while  I'm beginning to wish we'd never met  save yourself  I have a wish  [Music]